hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in metaphysics book 1 Aristotle
discusses four main fundamental clauses
and he also discusses his predecessors
in physics and metaphysics how they
understood the universe and the things
in it in terms of these causes and he
folds them for having overlooked or
underplayed if not all of the causes at
least some of them and one of the
important transitions that takes place
in his discussion is from accounts that
began by looking just at material causes
what it is that things are made of or
the substrate that they all depend on
and our modalities of that was
insufficient so there were accounts that
took that and then introduced another
cause which by convention we typically
call the efficient cause Aristotle talks
about it as the cause which is the arc a
the beginning or the the one that brings
about motion kinases or change metabolic
in Greek and this is an important new
step
in the account because as he says if you
want to say that the reason why things
are as they are why they have the being
they do why they have the structure
properties that they do that's not going
to work for some things you can't take a
bed and say well the wood just grew that
way right you're not gonna get a bed
from that nor are you gonna get a bronze
statue just from bronze itself or the
nature of the universe putting things
together in that way so there has to be
something else and what Aristotle
focuses on here is not just something
along the lines of billiard balls
running into each other those are
efficient clauses right a billiard ball
that hits another one communicates a
certain motion to it you can say that
that's an efficient cause but efficient
causality goes far beyond that so if we
think for example about a bed maker or a
statue maker as a cause for the
existence of the bed or the
configuration of the bed or of the
statue they're taking a certain material
and then they're imposing on at a
certain structure or form or shape a
certain essence as Aristotle would say
and they are communicating or imposing
or causing something to be right there's
a there's a motion on their part or a
change on their part that is producing
another motion or change so it's not
just random things colliding with each
other or mechanistically determined
things affecting each other in this way
that Aristotle has in mind
in fact what he's really interested in
here and he takes his predecessors as
being particularly interested in is
explaining something a bit a little bit
different why are things so well or
beautifully arranged ordered wide and
well put together things exist at all
the Greek for that is oh well right
carlos in the adverbial form i came to
be in a certain way to be in a
configuration to hold quite literally
why is that the case and so we can bring
in additional first principles to
account for this and he talks about
three people in particular he also does
bring up Parmenides and a few other
people in the course of this discussion
but the ones that we're really most
interested in are Hesiod and then more
than him empedocles and an exaggerated
what does he credit Hesiod
with having done for us he says it might
be inferred that the first person to
consider this question the question of
why are things arranged in the way that
they are how do things wind up this way
it wasn't just the materials what
arranged them that way was Hesiod and he
said or indeed anyone who assumed love
eros or desire at Bethulia as a first
principle and things he says well
Parmenides would be an example of this
then he goes back to Hesiod and Hesiod
in his poetry the the possession is a
poet who's providing mythological
accounts genealogies of how things got
to be he writes a work that is you know
the cosmogony right and Theogony so he
says where he's describing the creation
the universe Hesiod says love she
created first of all the gods
first of all things was chaos made and
then broad was immed earth and love the
foremost of immortal beings so love is
not the very first thing but once love
shows up on the scene love arranges
things love makes things happen
love introduces something new to the
order of the rather chaos the the just
material stuff and willy-nilly of the
universe he goes on and then he starts
talking about impetus
now in pet achlys if you remember
thought that there were elements basic
building blocks of manner and to the
water and air and fire of solace and
annex Emma knees and Heraclitus
Aristotle says that in pet that impetus
adds earth although he doesn't treat
these quite as consistently as Aristotle
would like and impetus introduces to
other things that provide an explanatory
account for how all these elements get
put together so he tells us that here we
go in view of this question why is it
that there are in some respect more bad
things and common things or base things
then there are good and beautiful things
and peda Cleese had an answer to this he
introduced love or friendship is another
way to translate it feely huh you know
common bond that holds things together
and strife nakos contention with each
other he introduces these as explanatory
principles so when things are
beautifully arranged it's because love
or friendship harmonizes all of these
things or elements or forces together
and when there's disruption when there's
chaos when there's ugliness when there's
sort of a discordant sand conflict
that's because strife introduces that
into these things and makes them not fit
in well with each other
Aristotle says this really doesn't
provide us that great of a account but
what's what's kind of interesting in it
is he says it would be correct
in a sense to say that empedocles spoke
of evil and good as first principles and
was the first to do so that is if the
cause of all good things
is good itself now an exec is he talks
about in passing but annex a gross
introduces yet another way of looking at
things another principle mind news
intellect is another way of translating
that as well and according to an exact
mind originally arranges everything he
says that Aristotle says that an exact
receive Ailes himself of mind as an
artificial device he calls this a makin
a race tire right he uses it in that way
to arrange the universe to put
everything in order
Cosmo poi on right and then he says
unfortunately at once he introduces this
account an exact result awk about
anything other than mind as being the
causes of things so he uses mind to get
everything arranged at the beginning of
any forgets about it later on coming
back to impetus very quickly he says
that impediment from his predecessors by
introducing a division in this caused a
division not just in the material cause
but in the efficient cause two types of
them friendship or love and and strife
now Aristotle thinks that all of these
accounts are defective in some ways the
biggest problem is that they don't take
account of what he calls the final cause
now that's not completely unique to
these thinkers as a matter of fact
Aristotle thinks that nobody has really
discussed the final cause adequately by
comparison to himself and he's going to
introduce a lot of key characteristics
of it but with respect to these thinkers
he says
what they do is they assume that mind or
friendship is some sort of good thing
and he thinks they're completely right
about that but then they view them just
as the origins of motion they treat them
as efficient causes they get things
started but there's no realization that
there's another key function to this
this cause he says nothing is in their
accounts
nothing is or comes about for the sake
hosts Chanukah to tone in in the Greek
of this great good whatever it happens
to be friendship mind love desire so
there's no conception of it being the
final end or good instead it's just the
originator of motion and we're left with
a rather defective account one that
can't sufficiently explain why things
are the way they are as Aristotle is
looking for in his metaphysics
you